parfois la police connaissait la
dernière planque de l'ennemi public
numéro 1 un appartenant au 35 de la rue
belliard dans le 18e à quelques
centaines d'ascètes ici porte de
clignancourt que tout s'est passé
d'après midi la voiture de mesrine s'est
présentée au milieu de la place
elle a immédiatement été cerné par
plusieurs voitures
les policiers une trentaine d'hommes
environ ouvert le feu
la bmw de mesrine a été criblée de
balles il n'a pas eu le temps de se
servir des deux grenades qu'il avait
glissé sous son siège et il a trouvé la
mort immédiatement sa campagne qui vient
d'être évacuée il ya quelques instants
et blessés civils jean-jacques rollat me
de mesrine est actuellement opéré
atteinte de plusieurs balles son état
est très grave
quant à jacques mesrine il était encore
au volant de sa voiture morts lorsque
les premiers journalistes sont arrivés
porte de clignancourt
celui que l'on appelait l'ennemi public
numéro 1 avait le corps criblé de balles
le visage défiguré sa ceinture de
sécurité était bouclé visiblement il
n'avait pas eu le temps d'esquisser le
moindre geste sur une aile de la bmw la
perruque rousse que portait et mesrine
son dernier déguisement sur place les
témoins de confirmer la fin de mesrine
n'avait duré que quelques secondes
on a vu une
une camionnette
de la police avec une police qui qui
tout d'un coup a fait une queue de
poisson à une voiture
je fais pas qui était là dedans bien
entendu c'est après j'ai appris que
cette énergie massereene
tu leur projet
monsieur de la voiture qui était censé
être merina fin d'après ce qu'on a vu à
prêts à vous douteriez n'a pas plu
puisqu'il y avait la fourgonnette de
police qui le bloquait et tout d'un coup
on a entendu une grosse rafale alors que
tout ce que j'ai fait ce moment c'est
d'aller me cacher
je ne pas être
/
pour le chant de d'éventuels pour porter
vers ma direction
j'avais l'impression qu'on lui avait
tendu un piège en quelque sorte
nettement l'impression que j'ai suivi ça
avait pas de doute c'est à dire que la
voiture a été coincé au beau milieu d'un
plat c'était vraiment un coup bien
préparé on l'avait bien la pression
cessé d un grand préparer à l'avance à
mon avis
même pas essayé de se défendre puisqu'il
avait encore la ceinture la ceinture il
pouvait quand même détaché sa ceinture
n'a vu sa ceinture de sécurité
il ya un peu plus d'une heure les
policiers ont arrêté un complice de
mesrine à la gare saint-lazare charlie
bauer était avec mesrine quand il avait
baissé jacques tillier le journaliste de
minute
mesrine a battu pour la police et la fin
d'une chasse à l'homme de 18 mois
jacques mesrine 43 ans est le fils
d'artisan brodeur c'est en 1962 qu'il
commet ses premiers méfaits détention
d'armes cambriolages attaques de banques
après diverses condamnations en france
par défaut en 1969 il émigre au canada
où il devient très rapidement l'ennemi
public numéro un
ils enlèvent industrielle touche 200
mille dollars mais arrêter en 71 il est
condamné à 10 ans de détention le 21
août 72 il s'évade du pénitencier
saint-vincent-de-paul au québec
un peu plus tard il attaquera cette
prison de haute surveillance pour tenter
de libérer quelques amis la même année
mesrine et un comparse tu de
garde-chasse québécois revenu
clandestinement en france
il commet une série de hold up avant
d'être arrêté à boulogne billancourt
trois modes prison seulement et il
s'évade du palais de justice de
compiègne après avoir pris en otage le
président du tribunal
trois mois de cavale et c'est une
nouvelle arrestation par le commissaire
broussard et la brigade de recherche et
d'intervention
il est condamné à 20 ans de réclusion
par la cour d'assises de paris le 8 mai
78 bénéficiant de complicités
il s'évade de la prison de la santé en
compagnie de baisse et de karmann rives
ce dernier sera abattu par un policier
28 mai 78 hold up au casino de deauville
mesrine est blessé mais il parie une
nouvelle fois à s'échapper joint 78
hold-up âpre avec prise d'otages à la
société générale du reims novembre 78 il
commet une agression chez le président
de la cour d'assises de paris m petit
cette action ne sera qu'une prise
d'otage manque juin 79 s'étant fait
passer pour un policier
il enlève le milliardaire de la sarthe
henri lelièvre ce dernier sera libéré
cinq semaines plus tard après avoir
versé une rançon de 6 millions de francs
le 10 septembre dernier enfin c'est
l'agression contre un journaliste de
minute jacques tiller blessée de trois
balles dans une grotte près de creil
durant sa cavale jacques mesrine aura
écrit quelques dizaines de lettres après
une chasse à l'homme qui a duré 18 mois
il a terminé sa retentissante carrière
criminelle sous les balles le vendredi 2
novembre 1979
monsieur maurice bouvier directeur de la
police judiciaire a expliqué hier soir
lors d'une conférence de presse
dans quelles circonstances les policiers
étaient intervenus confirmant ainsi les
informations précise que jean pierre
chapel vient de vous détailler
lorsque mesrine s'est vu entouré de
voiture il a entrouvert sa portière
nous savions qu'il avait avec lui des
grenades défensives et effectivement les
constatations ont permis d'établir qu'il
avait dans une sacoche ouverte à ses
pieds deux grenades défensives
à partir de là nous ne pouvions pas le
laisser utiliser ces grenades et nous
avons été amenés à tirer n'y a pas
d'autre moyen que de l'abattre
je crois vous avoir raconté les
conditions dans lesquelles nous sommes
intervenus
nous ne pouvions pas permettre un
mesrine de jeter une brega une grenade
et sur nos fonctionnaires et dans la
foule ce n'était pas possible d'autant
plus que je crois devoir vous rappeler
que dans tout ce qu'il a déclaré dans
les lettres qu'il vous a adressé annoncé
qu'ils tiraient sur nous lors du dernier
procès aux assises et en prêts devant la
cour et devant tous les journalistes il
s'est adressé au commissaire broussard
pour gagner la prochaine fois dans la
rue c'est celui qui tira le proc le
premier qui aura raison enfin lors de la
tentative de remise d'une rançon de
dammartin il a ouvert le feu sur les
voitures de police qui se trouvait
encore à 150 semaines
nous ne pouvions donc absolument pas
permettre que mesrine recommence s'il
était sorti en levant les mains la
situation va était tout à fait
différente
est-ce que sa surprise était totale ou
est ce qu'il a essayé de se défendre il
a ouvert la porte vous savez je crois
que tout a été extrêmement rapide et sa
réaction est la nôtre les policiers de
la berri et de l'eau crb des
commissaires bruce
art et mais blanc ont poursuivi
aujourd'hui dimanche leurs
investigations
il y a les fameuses cassettes
enregistrées une soixantaine au total
que l'on a retrouvé au domicile
clandestins de mesrine il y à sa
comptabilité très minutieuse il y a les
bijoux les armes récupérées et aussi
l'audition du complice de mesrine
charles bauer
cet après midi jacques collet a pu
assister au départ de boer pour la
prison de fleury mérogis et surtout
écoutés et enregistré la fameuse
cassette sur laquelle jacques mesrine
s'adresse à sa maîtresse charles bauer
36 ans c'est lui qui tend cette après
midi les locaux du quai des orfèvres
destination fleury mérogis auparavant il
avait avoué avoir participé à
l'agression contre le journaliste
jacques tillier et à l'enlèvement de
henri lelièvre avec jacques mesrine
évidemment par ailleurs le commissaire
devos s'est rendu cet après midi à
l'hôpital boucicaut pour y entendre
sylvia jeanjacquot pourtant le moment le
plus fort de cette enquête tels que les
journalistes l'ont ressentie en tout cas
c'est dans le bureau du procureur de la
république parce que le gunéhec que nous
l'avons connu cette cassette vous allez
l'entendre c'est un peu le testament de
jacques mesrine à sa maîtresse
le gangster a voulu y donner un ton
étrange en y superposant la musique du
film midnight express
certains en sont en face contrairement à
contrer stupide que c'eut été vendu à
dijon pour la ville en travaillant moins
patron de synergie possible la question
qui se pose pas dit comment il apporte
tellement de cadeaux à terre je mangeais
suivant les arabes à la main même chip
tête sa fille n'en sais rien je n'ai pas
eu à m'en servir parce que même si les
policiers l'ont tué avant que j'ai donc
mettre la main sur mon honneur
il faut dire une chose si j'avais dit en
outre la manne qui joue on sera servi
peut-être que je suis là maintenu et que
je m'en suis servi puisque cette
cassette est prémonitoire
je ne peux pas quand même envisager ce
qui m'est arrivé où ce qui m'arrivera
mais surtout sachets c'est que si tu es
un coût de cette pièce elle sait que je
suis dans une
celui dont on ne sait pas pas
[Musique]